nous avons autorisé
l'utilisation du pass sanitaire
seulement jusqu'au 15 novembre
la loi est entrée en vigueur le 9 août
nous sommes un peu plus que la moitié du
chemin
il va y avoir encore quelques semaines
qui vont se passer nous devons évaluer
la situation sanitaire est la situation
des vaccinations au moment de prendre
une nouvelle décision je trouve qu'il
est beaucoup trop tôt pour le faire et
je trouve que quand on aura atteint un
taux d'immunisation de la population
suffisant par la vaccination
il faudra prendre l'habitude de lutter
contre le coc vide par d'autres moyens
que les contraintes exercées sur les 85
ou 90% de personnes vaccinées pour la
protection des 10% qui ne le serait pas
et qui devront alors prendre des mesures
pour assurer leur propre sécurité
sanitaire par le respect d'un certain
nombre de gestes et de précautions à
prendre si on n'est pas vaccinée on va
prendre des précautions particulières ce
n'est pas tout la population qui doit
les prendre pour vous on entend vous
appelez à différencier les mesures
restrictives des libertés individuelles
en fonction de son statut de vaccination
un mot sur cette date de l'été ça semble
une perspective très lointaine est ce
que c'est ce serait envisageable pour
vous de voter un texte qui donnerait de
telles échéances non je ne veux pas
différencier les contraintes je veux
dire qu'on ne va pas appliquer des
contraintes pour toute la population
parce que 10% ne seraient pas vaccinés
ou 15% ne seraient pas vaccinés donc je
veux pouvoir faire un bilan exact car
avant de proposer une décision au sénat
et en tout état de cause jamais depuis
le début de la crise sanitaire mais
jamais non plus quand il s'est agit de
lutter contre le terrorisme avec l'état
d'urgence contre le terrorisme nous
n'avons autorisé le gouvernement à
exercer en quelque sorte les pleins
pouvoirs
pour lutter contre la crise pendant une
aussi longue période donc il y aura à
coup sûr un débat très approfondie sur
l'ensemble de ces questions allez un
moment